so
what what is the point of life is is
anything
sacred that did such a question even
make sense but this is what religious
people are worried about
and i think these questions do make
sense and there are answers to them
but the answers are not a matter of
getting more information
the answer is a change in attitude
there are ways of experiencing life as
sacred
without without believing anything and
certainly without believing anything on
insufficient evidence
there are ways to to really live in the
present moment
okay what what's the alternative
okay it is always now
however much you feel you may need to
plan for the future
to anticipate it to mitigate risks the
reality of your life
is now
now that this may sound trite but it's
the truth
it's not quite true as a matter of
physics in fact there's there is no
now that encompasses the entire universe
you can't talk about an event
being simultaneously occurring here and
one
at the same moment occurring in
andromeda
the truth is now is not even well
defined as a matter of neurology
because we know that inputs to the brain
come at different moments and
that consciousness is is built upon
layers of inputs whose timings have to
be different
you just consider the sensation of of
touching your finger to your nose
it seems simultaneous as a matter of
conscious experience
but we know that the input from the
finger to sensory cortex must take
longer
than the input from your nose and this
is true no matter how short your arms
are along your nose
the so so the brain buffers these inputs
in some way in memory and then promotes
the seeming simultaneity to
consciousness and and so you're so
our conscious awareness of the present
moment is in some relevant sense already
a memory
but as a matter of conscious experience
the reality of your life
is always now
and i think this is a liberating truth
about the nature of the human mind in
fact i think there's probably
nothing more important to understand
about your mind than that if you want to
be happy in this world
but the past is a memory
it's a thought arising in the present
that the future is merely anticipated it
is another thought
arising now
what we truly have
is this moment
and this
and and we spend most of our lives
forgetting this truth
repudiating it fleeing it overlooking it
and and the the horror is that we
succeed
we we managed to never really connect
with the present moment and find
fulfillment there because we are we are
continually hoping to become happy in
the future
and the future never arrives
now even when we think we're in the
present moment we're in very subtle ways
always looking over its shoulder
anticipating what's coming next we're
always solving a problem
and it's possible to simply drop your
problem
if only for a moment and enjoy whatever
is true of your life in the present
or what whatever you can possibly notice
in your body in your mind in the world
has only one place to appear
in your conscious experience
now i'm not saying this is all just a
dream
but as a neurological matter it is very
much like a dream it is a dream that is
constrained
by inputs from the external world
and the dreams we call dreams at night
are dreams that are not constrained
by the external world and that's why you
seem to be able to get away with
everything
but your mind is all you have
okay it's all you've ever had it's all
you have to offer other people okay and
then this might sound
callous to say when that when there may
be many other aspects of your life that
seem
in need of being addressed
when you when you're trying to
struggling to find a career or
or you're sick but it's still true
if you're perpetually angry and
depressed and confused and unloving
it doesn't matter how much success you
have or who is in your life
you're not going to enjoy any of it
i suspect you could all make a list of
things you want to accomplish
of things you that really need to be
changed about your life
what is the significance of everything
on that list
each thing on the list seems to promise
that if you could only do it
you would have reason to just be happy
in the present moment we are all trying
to find a path
back to the present moment and good
enough reason
to just be happy here
[Music]
and again i'm not saying that everything
on your on your list is absurd
or not worth accomplishing but how
dissatisfied with the present
do you have to be in order to prepare a
satisfying future
how neurotic do you have to be how
unhappy do you have to be
how much stress do you have to feel
how unpleasant do you have to be for
other people to be around
where if you're constantly ruminating
about what you just did or what you
should have done or what you would have
done if you
if you only had the chance you will miss
your life
you'll fail to connect with it you'll
fail to connect with other people
when other people talk you'll be waiting
for them to shut up so that you can say
what's on your mind to say
even when you don't have an opportunity
to talk in a moment like this when
you're just
when you just need to listen
you're the conversation as an
automaticity continues
you have a voice in your head that keeps
saying things
haven't you noticed
the conversation we have with ourselves
every minute of the day
comes at a cost it's i'm not saying that
discursive thought is not necessary or
useful
but it is the mechanism by which most of
our suffering is inflicted
the sorrow and the self-doubt and the
anxiety and the fear
and yes the fear of death
being thinking is useful but being
perpetually lost in thought
isn't okay being the mere hostage of the
next thought that comes careening into
consciousness
isn't useful
so if there's an antidote to the fear of
death
and the experience of loss that's
compatible with reason
i think it's to be found here